liderado por jeffeny pregojin el grupo
paramilitar ruso Wagner ha tenido un
foco de caza favorito en los últimos
años África un continente donde sus
mercenarios están ahora presentes en
unos 15 países
entrenando al ejército y a la guardia
presidencial en la República
centroafricana reprimiendo
manifestaciones contra el bachill en
Sudán la insurrección en mozambique
entregando armas y combatiendo con el
ejército del Mariscal haftar en Libia
sus misiones varían de un país a otro el
modelo económico africano de Wagner es
siempre el mismo la depredación de los
recursos locales a cambio de sus
servicios como en Mali y la república
centroafricana donde el grupo ha puesto
sus manos en varias de las minas de oro
del país el resultado es una enorme
ganancia financiera incalculable pero
esencial para financiar las operaciones
en Ucrania en los últimos meses y para
pagar bien a sus hombres la cuestión una
hora es el motín abordado en los últimos
días incitará a otros países a expulsar
a Wagner de su territorio y así privarlo
de gran parte de su financiación para la
jefa de la diplomacia francesa Catherine
Corona aún tenemos que esperar
creo que es demasiado pronto para sacar
todas las conclusiones de estos
acontecimientos sobre el terreno en
Rusia alrededor de Rusia y ciertamente
también en África esto merece toda
nuestra atención y Seguiremos
extremadamente atentos y vigilantes
sobre las actividades de Wagner
hasta el momento ningún país africano
con presencia de Wagner en su suelo ha
expresado el deseo de ver a sus
mercenarios hacer las maletas